and finally new role let's not forget
that today May 1st is the anniversary of
the day in 2003 when George Bush landed
on an aircraft carrier and prematurely
announced mission accomplished in the
Iraq war and somehow possibly because
Obama is a ninja warrior today May 1st
is also the day in 2011 when he actually
accomplished the mission by ordering
SEAL Team 6 to killed in Lund so I say
let's make May 1st to holiday and call
it national do this not that day or as
they used to say on romper room be a mr.
Dubey not a mister don't be now how many
of you boys and girls remember romper
room for you millenials romper room was
this show they used to have on for
preschoolers to bore you into taking a
nap in the days before Ritalin and two
of the recurring characters on it were
mr. Dubey who was always doing
everything right and mr. don't be who
was a huge [ __ ] and I credit romper
room with making me a person who always
wanted to do everything right which is
why did this day people refer to me as
mr. Dubey
at least I think that's why anyway
robber room went off in 1994 which is a
shame because misters dooby and don't be
would have been perfect to help us
illustrate our national do this not that
day
for example after an attack on America
mister don't be panics and invades the
wrong country
mr. Dubey focuses on the real attacker
and shoots him in the face mr. junkie
makes up stories about nukes in Iraq
that don't exist mr. Dubey makes a
treaty with Iran so they don't build
nukes at all mister don't be tortures
prisoners mr. Dubey says sounds bad
mr. dopey gets his actionable Intel from
Jesus mr. Dubey gets his from tapping
your phone
mr. doobies best foreign policy move
brings our casualty rate down by over
60% mr. don't B's best foreign policy
move was dodging a shoe well you get the
idea I don't mean to make it sound all
black and white but you know we were
baited baited into an unnecessary war
that cost thousands of lives and
trillions of dollars and what did it
really get us besides an Oscar
nomination for bradley cooper islamic
extremists run places where they never
even existed before and isis was created
isis who's now trying to do the same
thing to us beta s-- they say [ __ ] in
your pants and we say how much we've
learned nothing the republican campaign
trail today is the same empty tough guy
talk from chickenhawks same as it was in
2003
Mike Mike Huckabee says you don't try to
reason with a snake you get a shotgun
and take the snake's head off or how
about this you leave the snake alone
just as once go to church and handle
something else
you know I I've been in the woods I've
never once had a snake problem that
couldn't be solved by distance distance
pretty much any terrorist who ever
attacked us and live to tell why has
said some variation of the same thing
hey idiots we don't hate you for your
freedom we could give a goat [ __ ] about
your freedom we hate you for your
proximity because you're there in our
land
if it helps you conservatives think of
it this way you don't like Mexicans in
your country and all they want to do is
mow your lawn the old plan have let them
hate us so long as they fear isn't
working let's try absence makes the
heart grow fonder President Obama once
said we need to do more than end a war
we need to end the mindset that got us
into war yes a mindset that centuries
old blood feuds are going to be resolved
because we said so the mindset that
star-spangled American freedom is the
salle that heals all wounds when
everyone knows that's Jagermeister
you